yellow welcome to this video as promised
yesterday this will be a wrap-up video
here for the Sun masters final
tournament started in Sao Paulo about
two weeks ago on even to an arc weeks
and the last second like had been played
now my bow and today has been the last
round before the last round we had
corona and cards and leading the
tournament and they actually had such a
huge lead that they were the only
contenders to win the tournament so and
they both share the lead Anton both had
like today um the rules are if to play
us tie for first place there will be on
a blitz playoff so keep that in mind um
I don't have um lots of time today to do
a really long video so I go go through
all this some a bit quicker than then
usual so let's start with the game
vallejo against Cara wanna this was
really a quick game we have a ruler pass
and it all follows the well-known main
lines with 983 um yeah here black of
course has a huge choice Caruana went
for rookie aid which is some the
introductory the first move of most
probably most likely the desired set
variation which very often also starts
with Bishop d7 so Bishop v 7d for rookie
a this another move water he started
with rookie Aidan now vallejo went 95
yeah this is a well-known um yeah answer
to this move with f7 now under tech and
black actually doesn't have any
alternative to just drop the rook back
and now why just returned rookie yet
again and 95 you can
imagine that this kind of repetition has
happened a lot i'm living in the past
i'm leading to a good draw now Vallejo
PD for which would to be seven back back
to f3 Andrew p8 so black is just playing
the this line and well I hope simply
wants to wrap the game up with the draw
so they em played a couple of those it
looks night and rook moves and and it
was a draw after nineteen moves yeah
always disappointed disappointing to see
a game finished so quickly in the last
round um yeah it's um not much you can
do as a spectator at some I guess they
had I'm not quite sure about the rules
and what was that in terms of draw some
yeah I think it's a bit of a shame that
this game finished so quickly but of
course it's a matter of the white player
I mean like it's just playing a main
line and the the white player simply
decides to go for this draw so I'm not
much blame on Caruana but I'm not quite
sure um it's understandable after a
tournament that has been long and pretty
young pretty difficult for vallejo that
he wants to wrap it up but yeah it's um
not too great for the spectators so Kara
wanna with the draw so let's see what
Magnus did he played them against them
aronian so also with like of course and
as usual aronian played one before and
we got a Queen's Indian so novel normal
opening nothing extraordinary and our
only play g3 did sister I think what he
usually does and now I'm slide surprise
with Bishop d7 nowadays some Bishop a
success by far the main move but just
this move has some odds a little bit
sharper and allows white phone allows
allows why to try some
some some sharper systems some sharper
options like Quincy to see 55 this kind
of things we should be seven is just the
tried and trusted classical mainline you
should everything's pretty normal 93
here and 94 yeah this is played down
literally thousands of times um Bishop
b2 is probably the main move nowadays
and Bishop f6 yeah this has been played
as mentioned lots of times yeah iam
Aronian um later slightly surprising
move he played a 95 the normal way to to
play this position is it's a mouflon
move like am rook c1 and it continues
from here some questionable black what
would play now I can play em we can take
on d to I can play something like this I
mean there there are many possibilities
95 is a bit down uncommon though because
usually am you're thinking in this
position of black exchanges one or two
paths of minor pieces that he done
shouldn't have any big problems so 93
exchanging the Knights and exchanging
the bishops and yeah this really doesn't
look like much form for white ya can't
play D Phi which I thought was an
interesting decision like had
alternatives of course the fiber said
not bad and i'm not i'm not saying this
but you could could think of other are
the ideas let's say for example
something like these six was was
certainly possible going for a
completely a different setup let's say
Knight f3 maybe also Knight g4 as an
idea it's a bit bit strange this
position for the night but not bad let's
say neither three and then something
like
this end intending see 5 45 which also
looks som like blackest doing doing okay
in terms of equalizing the game airplane
t5 would show sunday is fine no g-form
yeah attacking yeah or me introducing
the idea to take on f6 this could be M
happening for example of black would
take now so this kind of this kind of
idea not sure if it is great at the
moment but it's a general idea that is
some now in the position ya can't just
played 97 um yeah this mission 1 c 3 is
not really doing so much so it's hard to
believe that white should have anything
serious here Queen a form yeah this is
it's intense to to do something on c6
maybe infiltrate their and increasing
pressure also on d5 this way rooty 19 f
six young black needs to learn exchange
more pieces to avoid coming under huge
pressure the problem is this move b six
he ends in this position if the Pawn
would be on b7 this would be absolutely
nothing but in this kind of
configuration there's always c6 as the
possible weakness especially for for the
night we see this now happening 95 and
now black gown needs to play on a bit a
bit them accurately yeah so blood must
be cautious because of the six square
plate Queenie Edna 96 and King edge ATM
trying to play 256 next and he doesn't
want to get into any kind of trouble
water with them capture on
only seven with check so this is
prophylactic move f3 yeah this
introduces this idea to UM to get more
play going in the center and also it
prevents a possible 90 for a six yeah
this prepares the upcoming maneuver to
to free em free blacks position can see
em this happening now Bishop bird to e1
yeah this is mostly designed to clear
the C file so that you can actually get
some pressure here and of course this
Bishop might find a place here we should
be six Roxy one and now be five yeah
this was important um to UM to get this
movement and to free em to free the
position as black we see now what
happens white captured him and black got
this porn back so from material point of
view it is equal and it hurts you you
think that okay this night I'm it's
really dominating the position what the
problem is it it's very nicely place but
doesn't it take anything and if black
and manages to exchange it for example
with this idea um just one possibility
then there's simply nothing so it's um
it's not much why does a bit better but
it's not much really Bishop to a five
and a queen eight now yeah this this
whole thing was was preparation for
night b8 getting rid of this the night
d3 and loopy idea ni PA tande now this
night will get exchanged it also cannot
cannot move because if I was hanging so
white cannot go here because this is
simply gone then so white has not much
of an iterative to this this move
and down up like oops this was a wrong
button like took on c6 and yeah rook be
too yeah this book is really active and
this basically secures the draw there's
also this move from threatened now with
before getting lost so it's all quite
logical now this is a weakness but this
is also weakness added it simply
canceled some each other out yeah here
if why would have taken like and simply
take on before he always has this
counter play now and then there was
simply not much happening rugby 8 and
yeah and now we get this dead rook
endgame then played a couple of moves
but it's simply nothing happening yeah
not the most spectacular game but it's
difficult with black and certainly
cousin them didn't intend to play some
some I don't know super risky opening
two to get them winning chances at any
cost think this is simply what's a bit
unprofessional if you play the world
number two um you cannot go i don't know
and play some some wild gambit stuff um
alright so a pretty correct looking draw
so we had them a tight finish with them
both cards and Kara wanna leading the
tournament or winning it shared I think
they both had plus three winning three
games and against the yeah the other
competition the other guys and they
played 11 in their own mini match where
cars in one
this nice and cam that had presented a
couple of two days ago three days ago
this end game who's really great to
watch really you should watch this if
you if you didn't didn't do already and
Carlton lost the first game against
carwin and very first game of the
tournament where it was winning at some
point so if you would want this okay
then he would win that would have won
the tournament out right okay so these
were the two tournament games and then
as mentioned they had a blitz playoff
and okay I'm analyzing blitz games
deeply as some not something you should
you should do on a regular basis so I'll
go through this rather briefly we had a
ruler person carwin had white in the
first game and it is a two game mini
match blitz with four minutes and free
second increments so so rather a longer
form of let's not super quick I know
some of my mouse is not moving no it
does strange so I'm we got a Berlin
defense and corona goes for them the
mainline did the notorious endgame um
93-97 yeah this is all all very much
known in this position on the roof nine
black has a multitude of moves can go
king here on age 6 Bishop d7 and so on
and ninety seven is played this is also
a positive point about this opening
black has a utrom number of of different
different options that you can easily
confuse white with move waters so we
have this typical endgame h6 is some
plate to prevent 95 from coming at black
now I'm p passes the the switch of the
King to
what's the queenside more fairly normal
i must say that i'm not really am a huge
expert on this i played this line this
black gum a couple of times when i
started out with e45 is black because
you have have some some things to look
at besides Roy and I wanted a simple
rule of pest variation i played this end
game I'm dumb but I don't know don't
know it in much detail so i can't really
tell if this is anything spectacularly
you but my impression though is that why
doesn't have much in this position like
has managed to untangle himself here and
it's got an active night i'm still a
problem with this Bishop it's not doing
much can go to e7 but that's it probably
am i would say that it's about equal
yeah white managed to activate the night
like played h5 yeah now i think now
black is probably intending to play each
form blocking the the King side and
establishing this night for for even
longer yeah white right can Mego here
but so it's something that white needs
to to look at this age for idea played
edge for himself and now night to e6
some denied them we located one
important thing is that this is what
what I know about these positions if why
the exchanges only seven and gets into
this opposite colored bishops and game
this is often comfortable for black ass
these pawns get under attack by this
Bishop very very long run long term plan
he still took and now Karl
move g5 which is a bit risky in terms of
pawn structure these two points will be
isolated but like get some activity
still it's probably around round equal
yeah this was certainly the idea also
getting a night to deform this is a
problem this night is a bit stranded on
on b5 it's not doing much so he tried to
relocate it but in the process allowed
them night to deform in this position I
think white should probably simply play
90 to try to get rid of this night it
can like an exchange now with the guests
round equal play I could go here and
continue I guess it's a it's about equal
still not so much happening but Kara
wanna played this move and I think he
simply overlooked something because cars
are now just took it and probably he
really overlooked this at five
possibility which is threatened now
because yeah what what should you do now
he captured on d4 and in this position
you cannot grab on d4 because of f5 and
you simply lose the light it's a deadly
pin so he probably overlooked this the
times I am by the way not correct young
there was some real a issue but Kara
wanna was very much download time this
is what they said in the broadcast so he
probably overlooked some TF 5 and this
means that he'll simply lost him cannot
take on d4 you must must go to d3 and
now like just trade this down to him to
him usually am too big advantage in the
end game white them and now probably
should take on deform and it's the lost
yep but you need to try to get rid of
this pawn but he played rook f2 and now
I'm okay this kind of technical on
stuff is really easy for cards c5 is a
nice touch not recapturing but then
keeping this strong pawn or deform and
after a couple of moves here in fact
White has no way to stop the D porn from
promoting caruana resigned so he lost
the first blitz game in this playoff
yeah mostly due to this 94 blunder it
happens and so the second game Carson
had widened only needed to draw two to
win the tournament in this playoff yeah
note that e-cigs has played so so that
Magnus cannot play we should be five in
any kind of way which he did in the
tournament but he has an offbeat line
here so how was g3 so non theoretical
chess the a black Sam main try now is
said d5 after which white can take and
play d4 and it it opens up quickly and
most a lot of um yeah dangerous that
there are some some peace exchanges I
guess karana wanted a more complicated
game so he played b6 attacking now is
the for porn which was covered with with
the Queen simply d6d form so black is
going for a can of Hedgehog formation
castles yeah and one important thing is
here in this kind of standoffs around
the long diagonal is the idea if 5 and
black must be a really cautious that II
Pfeiffer's not they're not happening in
a very in a very bad moment so he played
now night 227
which was answered by rope t1 improving
the root position and probably also
intending stuff like this um in general
I think um what black plate is it's a
bit questionable but ok it's a blitz
game and you you need to win somehow I
think this is a bad form of a head shock
really yeah here black probably needed
to play a move like queen bee aid or
something getting out of the the D farm
um what you played is a six and the sum
as it happens instantly losses and we'll
see em ye five is so still the issue um
yeah now black gum needs to do something
here and there basically two moves that
you can play can take on g2 and record
player you could take here this would
this would lose the exchange this kind
of stuff compared to to the gamer this
is Sir yeah better but if you look at
this you're just an exchange down for
very little compensation and the game at
some it was even worse it took on g2 why
took on f6 and now okay the bishop is
hanging so you cannot simply take on f6
and if you go to to be seven white takes
on e6 and you can simply resign so yeah
this is this is just terrible this is
why you cannot retreat to to ne ne
square on this diagonal if you would go
to d5 one can simply play this and you
just win it's still this 96 some stuff
coming so you played a bishop to h3 and
now queen aged 5 and yeah I think yeah
this is actually a position about here
which you should resign but he
they didn't want to resign after 12
moves why detects the bishop and it
simply has no place to go the only thing
that at first you can mad think that
would be playlist this move but wyd can
take and then g6 is answered by karachi
7 it's it's quite funny and yeah what
why doesn't even need to move the Queen
and that's just winning here with what
is CM a piece enter yeah and and
everything so black gum can resign here
but he got injured a couple of moves not
not many yeah now we resigned being a
piece down for for nothing and we've got
the king also in the middle so I'm very
good win here for cards in the second
blitz game I'm not quite sure I think um
maybe tirana was tired or something it
was a bit of bit of a shame this uh this
um this quick loss IAM certainly it
wasn't too thrilled about the loss in
the first game but um well I guess maybe
Carson is just the much better blitz
player and this is also maybe a
psychological thing if you need to play
a blitz playoff after pretty on but
after tough tournament in which you
really played well I mean unquestionably
am caruana had a great tournament and
then you need to play against someone
which you know maybe you have a really
bad score against Simplot son look maybe
it's not good for you before your
attitude to the games yep okay so um
this tournament is finished with a share
to victory for cars like Caruana with
Magnus winning the playoff and he are
quite interesting exciting games in the
tournament I covered them a few of them
I hope you enjoyed it um and I'm not
quite sure what's next
coming up I think there's a tournament
in the Netherlands coming up and so I'll
keep watching out for four new
interesting games to two do annotations
upon yeah thanks for watching